Okay,
good morning.
Should be live here.
Let me make sure we have the title
category set.
And uh we will get to work today.
That's good enough, right?
That's good enough.
So the plan for today,
we went through pretty much all of ALGO
yesterday.
First of all, what the hell happened
here?
I actually think um
Thank you.
Hello, welcome both. Um, I think we can
actually just start a new session here.
Constellation was relatively clean to
begin with.
It's all pretty much handwritten.
Except for a few lines of loading at the
top
protein
needs a lot of work. Puffer CPU is
pretty much all handwritten. It's very
nice. Puffer an is just the puffer fish.
So yeah, we're pretty much just left
with puffer LCU. So we're going to do
this read
and actually
What are you busy with? I am just
starting on
refactors to puff her out.
this um this refactor.ext, by the way, I
just get sick of saying the same thing
every time. This is just like some basic
style stylistic information.
Yep. This is what I wanted to to do.
It's just ingesting this file.
so I use it because I don't have to sit
here waiting for it to spin for half an
hour.
So, I've already gone through this file
or most of this file several times.
Hello, Liberty.
Welcome.
Uh yeah, I don't like these macro error
checks.
Puffer 3 Maybe a little more. I'd say we
have the star chart, but uh GitHub
decided to break that recently.
Okay, this is just some basics, just
some like little
uh
that's just like some little C++ stuff
that I uh missed.
Make sure it's still fast.
Yep, perfect.
This is Pufferlib, the highest
performance reinforcement learning
library. I live stream most of the de uh
most of the development on this project.
Nope. Um, if you watch what I'm doing,
you will see that I'm pretty much doing
like pretty narrowly scoped changes.
I don't know if you just if you watch me
doing my work and you watch out like
someone like Yasine or whatever or
Elliot actually is Elliot's a good
example you'll see a world of
Hello. ish. Welcome.
Yeah, this is clearly stupid. Like,
and this is why I end up having to spend
so much time going through, cuz no
matter how careful you are, it always
sneaks dumb [ __ ] into your
Well, morning.
Lots of folks here today. That's cool.
Um, to give a quick summary then for
people. I don't know what's up with my
reream. Hang on. Uh, I am currently
going to be refactoring
probably all of Puffarel today, which is
our core file. It's 3600 lines. I got
through the,900 lines of Algo yesterday.
That code took me about 5 hours to go
through through and I'd say I covered
I probably covered like 85 90% of it.
There's still some things in there that
I'm not perfectly happy with, but they
sort of require me to set up a bigger
benchmark in order to edit them more
heavily. So, overall pretty good.
I know none of this though or nothing.
Yeah, man. Just start doing some
projects with us. Like, you want to jam
some really good and learn some
low-level and learn some cool AI stuff,
drop in the Discord. Build some cool
things.
It's way more accessible than you would
think. You basically only need like the
very very simplest bits of uh your very
first systems course to get started.
Now, obviously the core dev I'm doing
like there's a lot more going into that,
but we have lots of people that are
pretty new making environments.
It's really just about getting your
hands dirty and like learning
fundamentals.
And we've had lots of people that have
done that and then have gone on to build
rather impressive RLNs.
Hello Jess, welcome. Do you think you
are losing skills while coding like
this? Um, if you say while coding like
this, watch what I'm actually doing.
Like
what I just did here. This was
an order of four line change with some
[ __ ] hooked into the build that
shouldn't have existed in the first
place.
And you're going to see me making a lot
of like similar like three four line
changes like that.
do we need end of header here or can we
move it up?
Think it can get moved up.
I actually like to I actually end up
deleting a lot of the shitty LLM
comments. Jesse.
What?
That seems
Doesn't this seem weird?
you adding comments. Uh, I'm usually
trying to make more narrowly scoped
changes. Anyways,
you played chess with George. That's
funny.
So, wait, does that mean that our model
can beat George Hots at chess with just
RL?
That's fun.
Yes, it can.
It's fun. I mean, to be fair, I'm
probably like awful. I mean, I'm awful
awful at chess. I don't play. So,
and just give it some gross stuff. What
do we think about this innie.h though
not a big fan of the multiple includes.
Not a big fan.
Let's see what we got here.
stuff.
float to be float.
Oh,
I see.
Okay. So, we'll think about this thing,
but we should be fine for now. Let me
make sure it didn't make anything
slower.
It shouldn't. It should be exactly the
same.
Oh, we're good. It did change the
numeric.
We'll have to double check on those, but
I think we're fine for now.
You see how much I care about even these
little things like why the heck do we
have a couple extra macros and crap?
It it like this is what research is
though, right? It's like experimenting,
trying to expose specific deficiencies
in a way that we can actually model and
improve.
Like research is tough.
It can be made like it can be made
fairly simple though.
Let's do
put this here.
Like this more.
And this we already refactored a little
bit.
Hang on. Wait. Does precision always
exist?
We have Pre.
Little screwy here. I don't not too
worried though. Cast are just going to
be slightly obnoxious regardless. Right,
Rock. So man, I I answer this question
so many times. It's just faster. It's
not that complicated.
Like the model is just faster. That's
it. It's not that deep.
Like why do we have stupid comments
where they don't need to be?
Used reward plus terminal cast.
I mean, I probably like YouTube and
Twitch both have commands for this crap,
right?
I will say that is sometimes like that
is one of the things I do wish we had a
lot of the time and see but like
you can also kind of clearly see why you
wouldn't
opinions on heristic what do you mean
heristic learning
Configs more viable with selfplay.
That's interesting.
I don't know why my file doesn't like
load.
No, this is this is missing the ca like
this is missing the point. You can use
this for some stuff but this is not a
viable alternative.
Like yes, you can do breakout or
whatever the hell
People keep writing like crazy [ __ ]
because they don't understand that RL
actually works.
RL works in SIM. Well, we build a lot of
SIMs
and we actually do transfer them.
Good luck heristic. Like, good luck.
Just like, oh, let's get the LM to write
a script to control the humanoid to do
everything. Like, no.
Yeah, Nish, that's [ __ ] Like,
you simply can't do anything when the
code's that slow.
It's also not longer in the sense like
torch is 3 million lines. If anything
breaks, you're just [ __ ]
because the source code is unreadable.
LM generated garbage.
No, but the thing is you can't there is
not a mapping from policy logic to code.
There's not any reasonable mapping for
that. It's fuzzy.
How do you reason with knobheads? You
don't, Anesh.
This is um
one of the harder life lessons. It's not
a communication failure. Like sometimes
people are just too dumb to reason with.
they're fuzzy in a very specific way,
E10.
Like you could very easily get yourself
something where you train a 100,000
parameter policy,
but in order to do something roughly
similar, you need like, you know,
100,000 lines of code.
And then like let's also keep in mind
that RL is most useful in spaces where
intuition is really tough
where the LMS are essentially useless
because their intuitions aren't any
better than yours. They're literally
trained on human data.
It's hard to get physics working. Try
harder.
And there's like all sorts of little
things. I got to stop engaging with this
because I like we actually have hard
stuff to fix today.
Okay, if you want to write a direct
equivalence between those two things,
Ethan, you need a massive decision tree.
Massive decision tree.
Like if you write that out in code,
it's not like, oh, 100,000 parameter
network, you can just write a 40line
program or a 400 line program.
I really don't like rapping stuff like
this, you know.
I don't think it's worth having these
rappers.
training exploiters.
Uh I tried I didn't I used the same
reward function and I just trained
against them directly. When you say get
a different reward function though, like
you have to specify one, right?
It depends what type of robotics, man.
Like the humanoid stuff, realistically,
they're not going to use sim and they're
not going to use huristics. They're just
going to strap a bunch of data
collection stuff to people and then pay
them until they get a lot of data. Maybe
doing a little bit of stuff in sim.
It's totally feasible though to build
like a really good like uh 60 DOF or 40
Doof arm simulator for industrial
applications
dolphin demo on both and Cuda. What
happened to the guy that had like the um
that had the whole
the whole port.
still using dolphin. I thought it was
totally different. You can't create an N
for cleaning a house.
You can't create uristics for cleaning a
house either. So, it's moot.
I think there are much much better
things you could do. And the whole like
humanoid robotic housekeeper thing is
mostly just [ __ ] anyways.
So,
I don't know. You're comparing like dumb
approaches to a dumb problem.
Like there's not a single layer of that
whole thing that makes any sense.
I thought you could create a generalist
humanoid. You can create a general like
you can create a humanoid sim that's
reasonable. Yes. Um you can create an
environment that they can wander around
in. Yes. like coming up with tasks like
just whatever possible task.
I mean you could possibly do it. It
would be very expensive. And the thing
is it's just a place where like
you can probably do some of the work in
sim but then you just go grab human
data. Like just go collect a bunch of
human data. And it's very easy to do
that.
That's the thing. You don't need to
train a Roomba. It's a super like super
simple thing.
Sim gives you infinite data for stuff
that you've programmed in. Yes. Which is
why, you know, you can bootstrap with it
for sure.
I really don't even think humanoid
robotics matters that much long term.
I'm going to go out on a limb. You might
see a bunch of them because it's the fad
thing and like companies think it's like
a great way to make a bunch of money and
it's the future or whatever, but
eventually I think that you're going to
just get a bunch like of much simpler
specialized robots that can be designed
for a specific application very cheaply
and efficiently and that can do the same
task dramatically faster.
can't sims with LMS or something cuz the
LMS are [ __ ] and the Sim has to not
suck.
Well,
we're kind of not really using PO as is.
Like, we've made some improvements to
it.
If you just like implement the PO paper
it's written, you will not get the same
results as you get in Puffer Lib.
cuz like
let me see what the code looks like
here.
and a humanoid can build another
humanoid very
slowly
and probably with a human teleaoperating
it because you do not have the software
to let a humanoid build another humanoid
anyways.
It's just stupid. Like, it's really just
stupid if you start thinking about it
more deeply.
Like the thing is it's way easier to
just build the specialist robots like
see the commonalities see the repeatable
patterns and start automating that
rather than first we shall solve the
world and then having solved the world
we shall solve many simple problems
efficiently somehow
where the heck do We have activations
registered, man.
Nope. It's worth using this. Yeah, it's
worth using this because
because it's a tensor.
Robbo code. What branch most stable
testable with the new bots?
Uh, definitely
four definitely has it and I think 5C is
probably good as well.
most stables probably four.
Isn't that what I did? Or did I did I
merge robo selfplay?
I actually double checked that, Spencer.
If Robo selfplay got merged into four,
then you can just use four. Otherwise,
you got to still grab robo selfplay and
then you can grab five whenever.
Yeah, it's not an exponential E10. They
just lie about that [ __ ]
Hey, Ethan. I got a formula for you that
you'll really like. It's uh E= MC² + AI.
Robbo code exists.
Then grab the robo selfplay branch for
now, Spencer. And any idea that you if
like if you think something works, I can
pretty easily port stuff onto 5C.
I'm almost done with it. Like we are now
at um well, we're still at the top of
it. I did the whole algo file yesterday.
like there's still some small things I
want to update, but it's good enough to
ship if I had to ship it. Um, and today
I'm hoping to get through as much of
Puffarella as I can. Maybe all of it
since I've already done a lot of work on
it.
Okay, good.
Mhm.
Yeah. So selfplay stuff kind of hard.
This is Grock
on the right.
Okay, so the robot currently can't make
another robot. So it takes an unlimited
number of years.
The robot also running it for a year,
even if you did, cost more than it would
take to hire a person to build a robot.
So it's completely [ __ ] stupid.
Like please
like literally just like write down the
full stuff that you're saying and like
read through it and you will see it
makes absolutely no sense.
Is it running? No, it's literally it's
Grock running with Grock's CLI. That's
it.
There's nothing fancy here.
Yeah. Yeah.
And again, it's really it's like it's
not that deep. It's just the model is
faster.
I actually do recommend this though if
you um if you're doing like most of your
own dev and just need like little bits
of stuff here and there cuz it's much
much faster.
That's good.
Uh, this is one of those rare cases
where
I actually I really don't like aligning
equal signs
typically, but this is one of those rare
cases where like you're kind of trolling
if you don't.
That guy' be damned.
Right.
I think though we're down to 390 is like
I think I'm happy with all of this so
far.
Yeah, I'm happy with all this.
That's not bad. 10% done.
Almost.
Yeah. 10%.
Okay, so now we are to Vanad. That's
nice.
Um,
Yeah. So, that's going to be the next
thing I think to clean up is going to be
this GPU log path thing.
We'll take a quick look at it. I'm use
the restroom though. I will be back in a
couple minutes. Um, star puffer on
GitHub if you haven't already. I will be
right back and we will continue cleaning
this up.
Okay,
back.
This is kind of just like a whatever
thing. This is like I do this type of
thing when I know, okay, yeah, the
current code in this section's kind of
crap. Let's just see if there's
anything. If it finds anything, I go
from there. If not, I do it manually.
Oh, it's absolutely worth it to have um
I think it's absolutely worth it to have
your own GPU.
So, right now I've been doing all my
work this summer sshed into my um my
single GPU box. It's definitely worth it
to at least have a like an SSH box. The
exact thing that you want to buy is a 16
core AMD chip 9950X,
a 5090
And you make sure that the box has
Noctua fans.
That is my recommendation if you want
like a top end workstation.
Whether it's worth it to you financially
is another thing, but for me,
absolutely.
AMD GPUs? No, I said AMD CPU. 16 core
AMD CPU. 5090 GPU.
DJX Spark. Overpriced.
Just get yourself a 5090.
Now, of course, right, this is
this is if you're a researcher doing
serious research and you should have a
work like you should have a workstation.
If you're just doing some hobby stuff
once in a while, yeah, you can rent for
me. Absolutely worth
I actually ver I do not recommend having
your workstation be the one that's
physically plugged in to be like well
okay if you can only have one then yes
but I personally I think it's so much
better having like a workstation box and
an SSH box. The workstation box should
also have a GPU. It doesn't necessarily
have to have a super fast one though.
Oh yeah, Noctua fans for sure. I have a
whole bunch of machines that [ __ ]
rattle because they have cheap fans. Get
Noctuas.
If you don't have the money, then just
rent off a vast. You're fine.
you can play with that for sure.
Long term,
unless you're like absolute science type
and don't do any engineering, I do not
suggest working out of Jupyter
notebooks.
They kind of suck.
That said, Alec Radford kind of did
that. So, if you're Alec Radford, by all
means, do whatever you want.
He was there when I was at Open AI.
Like, man, Alec was just great. He was
just an overall swell guy.
Yeah, I'd say if you're a beginner, just
rent something off of and, you know,
look around for hardware deals online.
And if you see something that's like at
a hefty discount that looks like it
would be good, go for it. I don't
recommend the Intel chips
and I don't recommend cheap fans.
Publishing a paper is kind of more of
like a gambling goal than anything else.
Like you some absolute like a lot of the
papers that get published if not most of
them these days are just awful. They're
not even correct.
So I mean they're two different things,
right? They're two different goals. One
is like how do I do good research and
the other is how do I publish a paper?
You should view these two things as
completely separate, having almost no
overlap in your mind.
6,000. No. Um, it's not at all. 5090 is
you want a 5090.
You can benchmark it yourself. Just rent
them like 8x5090 off of is still the
best thing.
See, it's not even about the uh the cost
efficiency badge. It's about like one,
the Pecore Ecore split being a pain in
the ass, and two, about them having
shipped two consecutive generations of
chips that just fried.
that cost me like tens of thousands of
dollars in lost like or in hardware
damage basically
and um maintenance time.
4090 is totally fine. I have lots of
4090s. 4090s are totally fine if you
have extra to throw around. 5090 is a
nice upgrade at least for some um some
workloads.
Yeah. No, Intel's awful. I bought Intel
chips almost exclusively for a decade
and they shipped me two consecutive gen
chips. I think I got like four bad chips
in a batch of 10 at least.
And then like they got more bad chips.
It was awful.
And of course, you know, they'll only
replace the chips.
They won't like replace your now
questionable motherboard or your whole
system that's now like attached in with,
you know, everything's on the
motherboard for their stupid chip.
when at this point you just want to have
the whole system rebuilt on AMD.
Yeah. No,
that that was awful.
All right. Come on. We got to get a
little bit of work done here.
This refactor's got to get done.
It's really easy to do real work. You
just sit down and try to do real work.
Okay, that specifically Eton doing that
and getting you in caught will actually
get you expelled from your university if
you're a student.
in a just world. That would also get you
sent straight to the mines, but we can
discuss that another time.
And by minds, we mean data labeling
role.
from Stamford. Is this somebody I'm
supposed to know personally?
Don't think I knew a Shane in
I actually got affiliate on Twitch. I
set it I technically I can set it to
only 30 seconds of ads per hour, which
is what I was going to do. Uh, however,
if I do that, then it will show pre-roll
ads, which is even worse. So, if I set
three minutes of ads per hour is the
lowest number I can set it to um,
without triggering pre-roll ads.
data uh data labeling is kind of like
the meme thing where like a lot of meta
people that were doing research got
moved to data labeling.
Technically, I'll pro I think I can
probably just gift a few common people
subs and then that'll um that should
disable it.
Twitch doesn't force pre-roll ads. Well,
you should not get pre-roll ads on my
channel. Um, because if you're an
affiliate and you have a at least an
affiliate and you have your ads set up
to run at least 3 minutes an hour, it
disables pre-roll ads completely.
You can actually make it uh 30 seconds
of ads per hour, but then they just hit
everybody with pre-roll ads.
So basically like nobody actually goes
to the channel because everybody clicks
off stupid ad.
I'm letting this do an initial thing
just cuz I know that this has sort of
become a mess as long as it's a net line
of code cut and then we're going to go
through from there. I'm actually looking
here to make sure that this is not
editing anything high up like below
400ish
because I I want the head of the file to
be considered good.
If you're watching small streamers that
don't have affiliate, it might work
different.
like it might be different.
Oh, also, um, large streamers like they
have the ability to trigger like you can
set it up to always have pre-roll ads.
Like you can actually you can crank the
ads up on your channel to get a bigger
revenue share.
Like that is a thing you can do.
Yes, I started in NLP. I did like very
small but soda language modeling back
before transformers were a thing. Um and
then I did I did some work in vision
for about a year and then I moved to RL.
In fact, we used something from my NLP
work in the new architecture for Puffer
4.
This is my this is my first paper. This
is from NIPS 2017. It's not a great
paper. It's just like slamming two
existing approaches together and doing
some analysis. It's not a bad first
paper though. It's got simple little
math, simple little architecture stuff.
Um, but I actually remembered how well
uh highway connections worked over
layerm. And this actually was the main
thing that made the puffer for
architecture work.
So there you go.
The first RL research I ever did was in
Fe's lab as an intern when I was in high
school. World labs look cool. I don't
know whether like it's I don't know
whether the like train agents in world
model thing makes any sense, frankly. I
think they're probably useful for other
things.
Um, no Jess. So the new architecture was
not slamming two things together. So
slamming two things together is like
this is soda. This other thing is soda.
What if we do them both? The new
architecture was like, okay, here's
something that's pretty hardware aware.
like this should be able to be about the
same Perf but faster except that it lead
needs layerm. Here's this other thing
that I know is a good replacement for
layernorm in the setting where you need
something that is hardware efficient at
small model size. Like that was a much
more natural fit and required much more
insight about the details of both
approaches rather than just pick the top
two things and try them both at the same
time.
approaches
I read some spark but like
most papers I don't trust as far as I
can throw them.
Actually I can throw them pretty pretty
far. I don't trust as far as I can like
flick them with one finger.
Most papers are wrong.
Actually, that was one of the cool
things was because I did the research, I
remembered that the thing actually
worked.
Now, whether or not the thing was like,
you know, there were probably some other
things around that you could have tuned
to be like slightly soda over my thing.
That wasn't the point. I remembered
specifically
right that um you could replace layer
norm with highway connections. That was
the cool thing.
Um, that's actually a project I've been
wanting to do for a while. Jazz,
you could probably just I just need to
get like a graph of memory bandwidth
versus flops versus parameters for uh a
few different architectures.
But it's not about beating GPT, right?
It's like, hey, at small model size, the
ratio of flops to me usage is totally
off,
right?
And it's like very very poorly like the
architectures are very poorly
constructed for our hardware. There.
It is sort of weird dist like it is
right. And then the thing is if you're
training against a world model and the
world model's not updating, you're
basically just training an agent to poke
like like to make Swiss cheese out of
your world model.
It's very iffy.
I think world model stuff is cool. It's
very awesome. Like I just don't It's
weird for RL though.
We still have macro conditional crap
here.
See, it's still it's even iffy for
planning though because the world model
objective is much harder than the policy
objective.
So like you're learning a really hard
thing to help you learn the easy thing
better. Like it's just a mess.
I don't know. I'm mostly in my case, I'm
just betting on us building some pretty
damn good Sims.
Do Oh, you can reward hack the crap out
of our world models. Like literally the
original world models paper is just
like, "Hey, look how well these agents
hack the crap out of our our world
models, right?
like, oh, we're going to get a
projectile. Let's just dodge in a way
that makes the projectile disappear.
Solve reward hacking using crypto.
There's no way, my guy.
There's no way.
Reward hacking is
the thing is that reward hacking
it's a it's a discrepancy in
specification.
It's not like a bug per se.
It's like you thought that you gave one
set of instructions, but actually, you
know,
the the the thing that you had in mind
to satisfy those, there was another way
to do it that was better according to
the metric you defined. YouTube delayed
by 10 seconds. Twitch was pretty good on
latency when I checked yesterday.
I don't know if they bump like they
improve it once you get affiliate.
Um, apparently I like qualified by a
factor of five or 10 and I just never
set it up. I did that yesterday. So
hopefully Twitch is better. I don't
know.
I was hoping to stir more [ __ ] up with
this, but uh evidently not.
How long into the project? This project
3 years.
The last update alone, I haven't been as
consistent streaming for this update,
but the last update, I think I streamed,
was it like 900 hours or something.
Like, we literally have an article on
this.
If you check the articles, it's
literally just a collage. Like, this is
just a collage of all the streams.
900 plus hours live streamed over eight
months
just for the 30 to 40 version.
I mean, this one was nuts, though. That
was like I was I'm very proud of that
one, but that one like burnt me out for
a month.
I think I spent the next week after
after the release just getting like
three 399s in Runescape just like click
click me not want to do things. Click.
Click.
I mean, we have professional work around
Puffer, right?
So, there's stuff around Puffer, but
this is the core thing that makes
everything run.
fine. Let's say that we're like we're
allowed to do this.
Um
It took a while. Like it honestly it
took a while to ramp back up. I like I
still would not I'm not working on this
anywhere near as much as in 40.
It's good progress though nonetheless.
I mean, for was really a unique sort of
a time
where it really just was like a thousand
small incremental things to like slowly
take torch and transform it into puffer.
Huh?
Okay, we'll come back to this thing, but
like let's go look at where we're using
stuff.
Well, I'm obviously going to finish the
pro. Like, this is what I do with my
life, man. Like
the goal is to fix RL.
RL is going to just be stable, mature
tech in about the next year. And Puffer
Lib is going to be the reason why it is.
It's very close.
It's actually very close.
This is crap.
our Ve logic.
And what are we doing with this
up for GP? Okay, so we have a GPU
reduce.
I honestly think sample efficiency is
mostly a meme.
I mean, do you care? Look, we can do
this now.
Boom. That's how long it takes to train
breakout.
What change to get it from four? Uh,
asynchronous training,
GPU env.
We're not doing all GPU ends or
anything, don't worry. Like, it's still
going to be nice and easy to write CPU
ends. We're not even going to try to do
primarily GPU ends. We just added it as
a feature and I said I figured like
haha, let's just use this to solve
breakout in under a second. That'd be
funny.
Okay, this is
Yeah, this is a disaster here, right?
Like
Is this all CPU?
No. Dude, this is ridiculous.
Okay, let's actually figure out what the
[ __ ] because I'm not just going to keep
saying like make this less [ __ ] Um,
so we have a
GPUms are not good for complex
environments. They're good for
environments with like heavy physics and
stuff. They're actually very bad for
branchy environments.
those three minutes to the thing's an
hour. Lowest I can set it without
getting pre-rolls.
Um, RSI is actually a really interesting
topic though not remotely in the way
it's being considered at the moment.
I mean it's it's more in my mind like
why do we keep getting these log linear
curves with respect to any metric that
we measure and compute
you know why don't we have
why can't we get an like nice cohesive
ends where there's kind of a baseline
set of skills that you learn and then
those let you get like linear perf from
there
it's kind of tough because a lot of ends
like places where
Perf sort of bottlenecks out. It's
because there's this thing that you need
in intuition that you can't develop just
learning inside of that that And
This is still considered like [ __ ]
around territory.
How much code are we at? Okay, that's
fine.
Order something real quick.
Order a cable.
Oh, one other thing I got to take care
of real quick.
Yeah. So, it's obviously it's going to
be the VEC API because it's GPU, right?
Okay, we lose a little bit of profiling
on GPU.
This only deletes 25 lines and it drops
our profiling.
Take a look. So
this is forward.
Then we have
cutting it down and just like less jank
overall, man.
We need a way to not have this in macros
at all.
Let me use a restroom real quick and I'm
going to think about this. If we can
just not have this [ __ ] macroed at all,
it would make it much easier.
I hate macro conditionals so much. I'll
be right back.
Double check one other small thing here.
Just keep getting messages up on the
side.
See, it just doesn't come up with this
stuff on its own
is the funny thing.
Superhuman programming my ass.
It's a little bit tricky. So, to explain
what I'm trying to do here, we added
GPUM support
um cuz we're going to need that in the
future anyways and it would be a cool
demo.
But
I I sort of just like didn't really care
about the details. And now we have two
completely different vectorization paths
for CPU and GPU where we have a ton of
logic duplicated that doesn't need to
be. And it's really bloating the code
and making it a mess. So um it just has
to actually be designed correctly now as
well.
And evidently the models are not smart
enough to do that on their own.
No, that's nuts. Yeah, that's nuts.
Like going to back to OpenAI a week
later. That's nuts.
I don't think that you understand that
most of the people doing this already
have more money than they can spend.
Like
Wait, no, it just added this. [ __ ]
Let me see.
favorite Alec Radford story. I didn't
know him super well personally. Um I
spoke with him a few times. He was very
funny. He would like just he was not a
very good programmer. He was a really
smart guy. He just wasn't like a very
good engineer. So he had a really funny
way of mitigating that. He just wouldn't
let his code bases grow for very long.
like whenever he started a new project,
he'd just throw away all of his code and
just start from scratch, which like
honestly that's a really effective way
to mitigate the amount of damage you can
do in uh to a code base. The other thing
like I remember he he actually was a
pretty good speaker but
like I he gave actually a very good like
wellspoken presentation
about uh you know some of his thoughts
he was work and some of the stuff he was
working on but he gave it like pacing
back and forth looking directly at the
ground.
He was just a really funny guy, like
really smart guy, just nice guy as well.
Just had like all sorts of tendencies
and things he would do.
He also told us that like he uh he there
was one time he had like a desktop but
he didn't have a laptop and he he was at
like his own startup and uh he would
just like disassemble his desk desktop,
put all the parts in a small bag so that
they'd fit nicely and then like build
the desktop in five minutes when he got
to the office and then take it all apart
at the end of the day and bring it back.
Holy crap. This thing is [ __ ]
Oh my god.
I mean, it's not like he's like, it
wasn't like you'd talk to him and go
like, "Oh, yeah, this is definitely the
smartest dude at the company," or
anything. It was just like, "Yeah, he's
a smart guy, really nice guy. He's
working on some cool stuff, you know,
could work out.
Yeah, these language models are useful
tools, but they're kind of [ __ ]
Which is why it's like when you see like
the discussion on how we're going to
regulate the god we've made on Twitter
and then you go use the tools and
they're completely [ __ ] It's like
[ __ ] you lying pieces of [ __ ] You know,
you're a bunch of companies. You want to
make money. You want to drum up a bunch
of [ __ ] so you can reg capture
yourself a bunch of money and you know
it.
Well, Alman, you can tell he's lying
when his lips are moving.
Funny thing is, I actually don't think
Daario is lying. I think he's just
convinced himself of his own like crazy
[ __ ]
Demis I'll listen to.
Deus is chill. Damn, I will listen to
Yeah, I I honestly don't know what to
think of that crit because
it's like you see all the stuff on X and
then you go and use the tools and they
just like fail basic ass GPU
programming.
I like Ray though.
Rayson
like Rayb Rayb's awesome.
What's that have to do with anything?
Great. Compacting. Lovely. Why Grock?
Cuz it's faster.
Much faster. Where's the restroom while
this compacts real quick?
We just have to figure out. Usually the
thing is that there's some legitimate
thing that it's stuck on, but then the
thing is just buried in a bunch of like
obvious other things that need to be
fixed. I'll fix it.
Yeah, Jess, I'm trying to figure
something else out.
Okay.
Yes. Exactly what I thought. So, this
means that this thing is [ __ ]
[ __ ]
stupid ass LLMs, man.
Rookie programmer at best.
How the hell does it take me 20 minutes
to get it to be able to do Yes.
1:30. Yeah, exactly. It's It's 3
minutes. Was it not like that before,
guys?
Wasn't that what it was like yesterday
or no?
You can watch it on X if you don't mind
the latency. Obviously
YouTube if you like YouTube and Twitch
both have like the premium subs that
disable uh ads. So like watch it
wherever you don't get ads.
I have ad block. Yeah. Okay.
So annoying, let me tell you.
Like what?
I think it is probably just going to
isomorphic.
Hopefully we can get this without
messing it up here.
Okay, this is [ __ ] dumb, but
whatever.
We'll go through this.
If we can at least
just get rid of the macro conditionals,
I can work with that.
No, we're still good here,
right? Yeah, we're still good.
And okay, this is this is still where it
should be.
You see the amount of stuff though that
goes into That's
We'll deal with this conditional later.
That one's much easier.
This is actually better than before
though.
that's not bad.
the same line count roughly. Okay.
Okay. I swear if I see a macro
conditional in here, I'm going to flip.
Noob question. Puffer refer to something
specific.
Puffer lib.
We have puffer.ai right here.
Have all sorts of demos. We build ultra
high performance reinforcement learning.
Runs in your browser. Trains locally on
one GPU.
Took me like an hour to get this thing
to like remove basic macros.
I had to explain how compiler works to
lm. It has read the entire compiler
source in training. Lovely.
I should probably set the title.
What? What? I have it set to RL. I'll
set to RLdev.
That's fine.
didn't really do a good job with this
demo. So fun.
Nice.
That's uh that's actually pretty good.
So, you see how that just worked.
Okay. So, let's sort of explain just
what happened. Um,
so we had some utterly stupid macro
conditional stuff where we were like
compile time trying to have two
different code paths in the same file.
That was ridiculous. It took a little
restructuring to eliminate those that
for whatever reason Grock could not
figure out. Um so I had to go through
and just like you know precisely outline
okay this move this gets like unified
here and then this can be removed
because even though this is not valid at
runtime this is valid at compile time
and that's all you need blah blah blah.
And then the idea was that as soon as we
had this not two horrendously separate
compile time paths, there would be some
obvious cuts, which lo and behold, there
are,
right?
Ah, okay.
We will have to um
That's not actually a problem. We'll
think about what we do about that
warning, though.
What did this buy us? Oh, look at this.
Look at that. We're actually we're under
2.5K now. So, from my efforts today,
we actually were able to cut like 180
lines. No. Yeah.
80.
That's like 180 lines of code. That's
awesome.
Hell yeah, man.
Oh, wait. No, I'm a dumbass. I
accidentally deleted half of it. We cut
80 lines of code.
We still cut 80 lines. It's not 180
lines.
They're
arrows aren't supposed to exist in the
Damn.
Yeah. Um, I'm pretty sure that like most
of the actual stalls, even frame perfect
ones, like those are out of the game
because pro players can actually do
that.
The only one I know is like the ice
climbers one, but then Ice Climbers are
just banned as a character.
There might be some others.
at Ryan in the Discord if you want to
know if one exists. Ryan is really good
at that game.
We'll save some lines on stupid
comments, I'm sure.
We go past this. Didn't we actually deal
with
No, we didn't. Okay. This is actually
This was like part of the stuff from
yesterday. It's fine. This is actually
just cool. We're good here. Only thing I
see is this spacing.
the hell happened to our shared colonel?
Huh?
Do you play video games?
I don't know. Does this count?
Pretty much always have Runescape on the
side monitor. I've played lots of stuff.
By far Runescape's the game I just keep
coming back to though.
I don't know why these things are just
not smart.
What is it about, my guy? It's
Runescape. It's like one of the best
known games
that's possibly out there.
What's it about? It's about everything.
How long have I been live here? 3 hours
40.
I have another twoish hours to do this.
The refactor streams are somewhat
tiring. I will say
it's a little bit surprising how much
so.
How do you focus with Runescape to the
side?
Cuz look what I'm doing. like it's like
me multiple minutes between clicking
anything
and then it's like a it's basically the
same loop every time. Your brain very
quickly automates that to the point that
I don't even realize I'm clicking the
thing in between doing stuff.
It's not like a you fall behind thing.
It's mostly just like it's a really long
form progression game.
Like you get a fraction of a single
level in one skill if you leave it up to
the side all day.
Might click it every so often.
I know. It's very unique.
It's like at the same time Whoops.
At the same time, it's not like an idol
game where there's not actually gameplay
and you just like are it's actually
there is lots of very active content as
well. It's like I said, it's what's it
about? It's about everything.
At least in form in the terms of the uh
the gameplay loop,
it has some of the least and most
engaging gameplay
in the same game.
That's why it's cool.
Also, it's an awesome end for RL. Check
out Valo in the the Discord. He has some
awesome RL ends that are ported from
Runescape code.
Okay,
speaking of a fraction of a level per
day,
here's the uh fraction of the level.
Today happens to be a day where you get
a a new one. There you go.
Yeah. I mean, do you not expect the uh
the guy that kind of just like grinds
the RL stuff for years to also not have
like very long form other stuff going
on? It's it's kind of the vibe, you
know,
and that's only part of the game is the
funny part. Like there's also very very
active engaging portions as well.
A lot of worthwhile things in life are
just really long form grinds. Getting in
really good physical shape is the same
thing, which is why there's a surprising
number of really jacked powerlters that
play Runescape.
Funny enough,
my own numbers are kind of meh at the
moment. This is a big summer cut, so I'm
getting very lean. And then we'll get
back to uh heavier stuff in the winter.
I know. Before summer, I could bench two
plates for 10. And now I'm doing like
195 for 10,
but I'm also like at least 10 lbs
lighter.
I do wonder if this is um the best
reduction to be using.
This is where I just need to set some
time aside to learn more CUDA. I
understand what this is doing, but I
don't understand
um like perfwise, right, other
deterministic reductions and where one
would likely be better.
Nice.
It's very funny to me that it just
doesn't catch this stuff at all.
Nice. Very very nice. Right.
Very very nice. 11 more lines cut.
And that's a good primitive to have as
well.
If I publish this today,
um
there's sections of it I'd be pretty
disappointed with. Yeah, Jess.
I also I haven't really looked at the
protein code at all. I think I' I think
I'm like at an 8 and a half out of 10
happy with the ALGO CU code quality.
And then we're probably at like a seven
across this whole file, but that's
because like portions are nine and
portions are like four.
And also like the final polish is not
done either, right?
we need to get rid of the vein
conditional. We'll come back to that
though.
It's much better for sure.
This jank here is from selfplay.
I'm going to do this thing when I go
back to selfplay Robocode and all that
because I don't want to screw with it
otherwise. So, if we're just considering
Yeah, they've reduced. Okay, this is
better.
Yeah, I think you know it's really this
is not that bad except for the bank
stuff which is selfplay.
I think we're okay here.
We're good. We're all the way down to
vethread main.
All right, that's good.
One good piece of content.
slowly. We're getting there. You know
the code slowly improving. Okay.
We probably have to do a naming pass at
some point, but um
you know, we're getting better here.
How many uses do we have?
Three.
Jesus. This is only a third of the way
through the file though.
but I think that those looked fine to
me.
Yeah, this is like pretty conservative.
The thing is this is still not going to
be bought for at home. This will be
bought by clinics.
Yeah, this is fair. This to me is like
way more exciting than humanoid robots
ever will be.
Yeah, cuz there's a lot of RL robotic
stuff.
I am interested in stuff like that
though. It's like the put humanoids
everywhere. That's not as interesting to
me.
Like specialized
like super high efficiency task specific
robots. Those are actually pretty
awesome.
And then it's more about like how do you
get the process of
designing, training,
and obviously mass-producing.
How do you make that as efficient as
possible?
It's just a little bit overzealous,
right? No, it's worth me actually
looking.
Okay. Just to make sure we don't like
overdo the uh the renames, you know.
Yeah, I was worried like some of this
was just way too long. Like, do I really
need to split lines? Like, no. We just
had to do the names.
puffer fish ocean. Yep.
Yes, exactly.
You found the motif.
What? QGN the giant cyan puffer fish
floating above me
perhaps.
Yeah. So for folks watching, anybody
who's gotten here recently, um this is
the essentially the full core
infrastructure of Puffer Lib. It's this
one file just under 3600 lines now. And
in my mind, like
if this code isn't good, then what are
we building, right?
It's worth just really agonizing over a
lot of things.
Now,
it's tough because some things just have
to be complicated for Perf,
but we try to minimize as much as we
can.
for instance, crazy things like this
where you can't just issue copy
instructions normally like yeah
literally you do actually bottleneck on
this for small networks if you don't
write a custom kernel for almost
everything.
I could arguably probably get almost the
same perf for like 1 million parameter
plus models with like um maybe a
thousand fewer lines of code. But the
thing is you can solve real problems
with well under a million parameters.
And also for research you also
definitely need um models that are
smaller than that.
That's mostly where my mind is at while
I'm looking at this.
I'm like a little bit wary of like here
for instance something like this. We
could attempt to validate and see maybe
there is a simpler way to do this but
I kind of want to wait until I do a like
a big PF joint PFS cleanup thing because
you really want to have some nice
performance benchmarks before you start
messing with this. And I have some, but
not enough that I just want to start
messing with core too too much.
Took a long time to get to where we are
already.
I do have to go through this in more
detail,
fortunately.
Well, this one we've already gone
through. Okay, we can't jump ahead a
couple lines. It's fine.
That's kind of okay.
It's really not
I think we actually can afford to be
down to here now.
First third of it
Why the hell should you need to d type
correct?
What in the hell?
Okay,
here's what we're going to do.
Truck's decent. It's fast. A little
faster than other stuff.
Stupid thing, man.
Why would you just copy it by default?
Oh, okay. That's fine. That's legacy.
Then
I was like, is this a dumb C++? Yep, of
course it is. How do I know? Cuz it's
always every single time I see some dumb
[ __ ]
it's like always C++
like inventing a problem in like
Jupyter notebooks.
You don't have a full programming
environment, man.
Like you're there typing little snippets
of code into a cell.
So like that's if you're if you want to
do science then sure. If you want to do
science that happens to involve a little
bit of code then like sure. But the
thing with research is sometimes
research requires you to do a lot of
engineering. Oftenimes it requires a lot
of engineering and a Jupyter notebook is
an awful environment for that.
on CS research
if you don't want to be doing
engineering. Sure.
If you care at all about doing any here,
it's not even if you care about
engineering. It's if you care about
things that require good engineering,
then you don't be like you don't work in
a Jupyter notebook. [ __ ]
Jupiter notebook is the production
system. That's insane.
Just because like the way that people do
something is [ __ ] doesn't mean that
you should do something in a way that is
[ __ ]
Sure. Like people were using SP3 in
production as well to train it 300 steps
per second. That doesn't make it smart
and that doesn't mean it's a good idea
to spend your time doing that.
A lot of people get paid a lot of money
to do very stupid things.
Yes. So,
if you want to just be doing science and
you're not an engineer and you have no
interest in doing engineering
But then I question why you're watching
my channel
because this is pretty engineeringheavy
research.
Arguably the most engineering heavy
research in the entire damn field since
literally nobody else has bothered to
build a perform a system this high
performance in RL.
I need some work.
What? What is this?
Yeah, the Gro CLI is very nice.
Um,
I'm using it because it is significantly
faster than the other models
and I'm making pretty small edits.
Wait, what? Hang on. This is weird,
isn't it?
We have a Dota enthusiast. Do you
recognize?
Does this map look familiar to you at
all?
Does our agent get stuck?
I think it's uh Yeah, there you go.
This doesn't look like uh we updated the
model. This looks like a super old
model.
We fixed it so they don't get stuck on
stuff.
It's free if you have 800 gigs of VRAM
is uh that's a take.
Open AI5 is in my mind still the best
paper in the field.
How much compute does it need to
recreate OpenAI 5?
it really depends on how the game is
implemented
and how fast you could get it to run
headless.
I don't know if they had full source
access.
Probably,
but maybe not.
It would depend on how like if we could
just if we could prune anything that's
only used for graphics like could we get
it to be reasonably fast, right?
We'll leave these for now. We're going
to have to come up with better names.
No, you can scale the crap out of RL.
It's um it's just more complicated and
problemsp specific.
And while it's going to be incredibly
important,
like it's not as obvious to just like,
oh yeah, we're going to make coding
models and make a money printing
machine.
So, that even didn't really work. It was
more like we're going to go get
ludicrous amounts of money and then make
a machine that eats money and prints
some money and hopefully prints more
money than it eats.
I don't know.
The stuff we can do with traditional RL
is much cooler to me. And we're also
going to be able to do it on our own
terms without stupid amounts of compute.
We have we need stupid amounts of data.
But uh the cool thing is we can kind of
just simulate that.
So
pretty Nice.
I had to
in there in a Can't.
the solution with the disillusion with
ML academia. Oh yeah, it's a mess.
You're only now figuring that one out.
Better late than never, I suppose.
Also, I owe Muffin a code review
likely tomorrow.
auto research submitting 20 p. Yeah,
it's stupid.
But the thing is like you can kind of
just ignore that crap and find people
doing stuff that you care about.
and take a look at what's going on with
Puffer.
I saw a post on Twitter like, "Hey, you
know, every single review in my batch
that I had as the the meta reviewer was
like much worse than just a a thorough
chat GPT review would have been." It's
like, "So, we should replace the
reviewers with chat GPT." It's like, at
that point, no, you should just delete
the [ __ ] review process cuz it's
dead,
right?
I think that's at least a decently
thorough.
It's net negative. But also the um keep
in mind like we don't care about the
breakout diffs. So this is actually
minus 100.
Jesus. This is literally only halfway
through the file.
I don't think that people understand
like
how much code 1500 lines can be. Like
you can do absolutely nothing in 1500
lines,
but like dense code 1500 lines does a
lot of stuff.
I mean it's kind of like saying how much
can you possibly communicate right in
was 1500 lines is 50 lines a page should
we say so 30 pages how much can you
possibly communicate in like a lot right
uh, no. 1500 lines can take a year to
write depending on what it is. Like, you
can generate 1500 lines of garbage very
quickly,
but that doesn't [ __ ] matter.
You still cannot generate 1500 lines of
concise, efficient code in a complex
domain in an hour or really any amount
of time with these stupid models.
in this case, I'd say that without the
selfplay and without all the model
saving and stuff,
The whole infrastructure setup of puffer
is about 1500 lines.
So like cudigraph
asynchronous
roll out asynchronous environment
and inference
async training
um all the static memory like everything
being static memory fully reproducible.
It's a lot of infrastructure. Sure.
You can build a web app in like uh 200
lines. It's we just deploy our C
directly to the web. It's great.
Like all of puffer li all like our
entire core like everything here except
the M's is going to be around 10k lines.
Oh, shoot. I forgot. Hang on. I uh
I forgot to order
I will be very happy if I don't ever
have to write any significant amount of
Python again.
Such a [ __ ] trash language.
I don't really want to be splitting this
here, do I?
Nah, it's just the names, I think, cuz
like the names are too long.
How much more code's there in this
function?
Oh yeah, this is a big one.
the big function.
Yeah, you need to Exactly. It's like
simpler in theory until you try to make
anything fast at all and then you're
just [ __ ] and you come up with like
entire new architectures to work around
Python being slow because you can't
write a for loop.
Yeah, I got rid of all the macro
branching crap, at least for the uh the
GPU paths.
We still have a little bit of endside
stuff, but not bad.
Ah, basic.
No. Go away, Windows.
Stupid.
Oh, right, right, right. That's good.
I don't know. I'm forgetting [ __ ] Okay,
cool.
Yeah, exactly.
Hello, Arch.
This definitely needs a little bit more
work.
This whole setup function.
Yes, you sweep rewards.
That's standard. You just define a few
things that you think are reasonable and
then you throw them in as coefficients.
Though honestly
for Smash Bros. you should be able to
just do like win.
It's a short enough task.
size a lot of this crap
some lines.
You can just clank format [ __ ] but I
always find it you just get a better
result if you just do like rough
perceptive grouping of [ __ ]
I'm definitely going to start getting to
the point very quickly here though where
um this is no longer productive. I mean,
I'm basically just linting as you can
see.
So, I think
I think this is a good place to stop for
now.
Yeah, I think this is a good place to
stop. just shy of 3600 lines with having
added quite a bit more spacing.
we only ended up cutting a very small
amount of code, but I think that there's
a fair bit of clean up. Also, we're
going to get some of this back into
spacing soon.
10k is still a realistic target from
here.
We haven't even touched protein at all.
There definitely cuts in there.
Okay,
I'm happy with this for now. It's
progress. You know, it's going to be We
knew it was going to be about a week of
work. I did two days of it. I'm about
what, 40% done. We're on pace. Um, thank
you to everybody who's tuned in today
for the six hours of refactoring stream.
Going to be like this for a little bit.
It always happens like this when we're
doing um lots of engine whatnot.
There will hopefully be some more
research time and such soon.
Sorry, the puffer. Yes, indeed.
GitHub. Uh it's on GitHub. It's also
just at puffer.ai. So thank you all very